we are asked which problem can we solve
with 42 divided by seven and they
explain three different scenarios here
we need to pick one of them so pause
this video and have a go at it before we
work through it together
all right now let's work through this
together so let's see choice a says
steven packed 42 candy bars in his bag
he gave seven of them away to his
friends how many candy bars does steven
have left well this isn't a situation of
dividing this is a situation where he
starts with 42 and he takes seven of
them away so this would be the
expression 42 minus 7 not the expression
42 divided by 7.
rule that one out
julie has seven bags of jelly beans
there are 42 jelly beans in one bag how
many jelly beans does julie have
well for each of those seven bags she
has 42 jelly beans so this would be 7
times 42 not 42 divided by 7 rule that
one out
leslie ran for 42 minutes total in one
week if she ran the same number of
minutes each day
how many minutes did leslie run in one
day
so she ran 42 minutes in total in the
week and she ran the same amount every
day there are seven days in a week so if
we want to figure out how much did you
run per day you just divide the 42
minutes total divided by seven days in a
week to figure out this would tell you
right over here how many minutes leslie
ran each day and so that is the problem
that we would solve with 42 divided by
seven
let's do another example
here we are told caleb has 21 action
figures he puts three action figures in
each box what does the expression 21
divided by three represent so pause this
video again and see if you can answer
that
all right so this is a situation where
we're starting with 21 and we're
dividing it into groups of three
so
these are groups
groups
of
three
so this is going to tell us how many
groups we need if we're going to divide
21 into groups of 3. so if i wrote 21
divided by
3 and so this is groups of 3
groups
of 3 this is going to be equal to
something and many of you might know
what this is but this is going to tell
us how many groups how many groups and
here a box represents a group how many
groups
and so this is going to be the number of
boxes the number of action figures in
each box they already told us there's
three in each box so that would be
represented just by three and the total
number of action figures that would be
21 the number of boxes is the total
number divided by how many in each box
let's do another one
alex brian and marta split a box of 12
cookies evenly
which expression helps us find out how
many cookies each friend will receive so
pause this video again and see if you
can tackle it
all right so we're splitting 12 cookies
so we'll start with 12 and we need to
divide it and how many people are we
dividing it between well we're dividing
it between 1 alex 2 brian and three
people marta so we're going to divide it
into three equal groups and you might
know what that is but we don't have to
figure that out we just have to say hey
how many how many cookies does each of
the three people receive well it's going
to be 12 divided by 3 cookies so it is
this choice right over here
3 divided by 12 doesn't make sense in
this situation you don't have 3 cookies
and you're not dividing it amongst 12
people
and c doesn't make sense you're not just
taking 12 cookies and dividing it
between two people you're dividing it
between three people